don't try this at home it's gonna make
you lose your entire mind hi I'm Joyce
hi I'm Emily and today we're gonna be
making paper foods I can't whistle have
you ever played the flute before I
played the recorder huh the only flute
content that I know is Sasha flute which
is liselle's flute alright so I'm gonna
pull up a big ole tutorial here and they
can play a paper flute long waist long
little short way yeah short way short
don't listen to me I don't know I don't
know you were making the flu rubberband
on one side all right I don't think I
have it fisted all the way two slices
not too deep I'm afraid this is where
messes
[Music]
I'm gonna cut out a hole yeah won't be
the first time I'm doing a terrible job
you are doing amazing look at this how
are we supposed to cool it's working I
feel like I'm in like purgatory she's
not having fun okay I am scared to
destroy and then I make a weird ramp
thingy out of it yeah like can you see
that yeah I figure guys it's like up to
the hole so you just take your finger
off to the hole and then there's kind of
like a finger motion scared actually
[Applause]
where did we go wrong we failed the
first time in here really bad
it's a first you don't succeed try try
again
we talked though we got it I'm not
wearing French love the craft bandit cut
it so what's an inch
I'm proud of you I'm an artist drew
there are we've got this piece separated
here I fit and we're gonna get this
losers into the hole I'm gonna cut it
off this is so much harder than I
thought it would be I just want to make
a flute I just wanna make one that's all
I really want it's crying time hi time
to cry ties it stays who's gonna pinch
it so it stays thick the scissors
through here through there through the
hole we can see oh it's coming out of
[Music]
I think we might be onto something now I
think we call just place your top lip
over the top of the paper and your
bottom up under the front of the paper
inside the - this is 10 times harder
than you think this is really difficult
I'm getting really frustrated all right
I need a moment to breathe that's the
word I'm sorry sometimes you have to
throw it out and start over
versions 1 & 2 are a complete failure so
we've decided to use different paper
gonna use reusing card stock before now
we're using regular old printer paper we
roll we roll it this is gonna be amazing
Oh how'd you do moment of silence for
all the flutes that we've lost making
this videos see we're getting it down
again the methodology I mean yeah I'm
getting the art style of it it actually
it's pretty insane someone was just that
like drunken didn't like I said I'm
gonna make a flute out of paper that's
probably exactly I know I'm drunk right
now oh you know what I want to do
[Music]
we know how to make them we just haven't
made a successful one yeah no but I feel
like we're getting close Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
I want it to work so bad Joyce it's just
getting soggy Oh what what uh what meet
Emily lose her mind after all what was
the one experience that really put her
put her out oh well this one time she
thought it would be a good idea to try
to make a paper flute and how hard can
it be she thought how are you making a
paper poufy guess what um turns out it's
pretty hard I'm having a great time
making that all right you nap I'll work
on this cuz I'm about to lose it you're
missing me succeed
[Music]
enjoys feeling refreshed
no gonna be purgatory oh my god did we
die so much so much if you keep telling
it to yourself enough it's true I'm
getting so close I'm so close
remember how we started off and we were
happy and like a little shy and like had
the rest of our lives to look forward to
and now we're stuck making paper flutes
until we die I'm always paranoid that
I'm gonna get murdered I'm afraid I'm
afraid to do it again run that could
happen you know there are people in this
life who make the flute and who play the
flute we are neither but I want to be
both about this paper this hole Oh Joyce
I just want to make a paper player we're
so close we keep failing we keep failing
look I'm not gonna put this lightly
we're failing really hard
we're too determined ladies we're gonna
make a paper instrument so help us God
the cardstock
I know it's hard I can't get over guess
what it's not working haha
surprise oh sweet baby please just work
[Applause]
[Music]
I swear joy we have a tube I don't want
it to I want to live it's not even
folding anymore it's like completely
rebelling against me I love nothing more
than to just pretend like we never did
this this is like the simplest tutorial
on the planet and we can't freaking get
it I'm gonna flip I'm flipping out right
now I'm actually I'm actively flipping I
can't I don't well why do I have to be
anything for anyone it's all I need to
be myself complicated keep going let it
out we are infinitely finite I would not
venture to say I'm so we're fine I
didn't know this is gonna haunt me I
didn't either I thought we were gonna
make it like maybe maybe two or three
tries honestly I think we did it like
five or six times I'm starting to regret
I'm starting to like go down the list of
regrets just in my whole life this is
why you don't get too proud so why are
you proud this is what I would do that
that whole time
[Music]